saying earlier we're lucky to have some
of the people that made the movie here
tonight so I'd like to first welcome
Peter Bogdanovich
thank you
and also Cybill Shepherd is here tonight
also Timothy bottoms is here tonight
also Cloris Leachman is here tonight
we haven't seen each other for a while
not 40 years but well wanted to thank
everybody again thank you all for for
coming here tonight really means a lot
to to everybody here and it was really
great to see it on the big screen so
thanks very much to you guys again
really incredible
I'd like to thank I'd like to thank the
audience is a terrific audience it
played like gangbusters and I have to
thank Grover crisp for at Sony him it's
a beautiful print the best pretty ever
had it's okay Peter maybe I'll just go
ahead and start with you if that's all
right I was gonna maybe want to Luke
okay I was just going to ask you maybe
how you kind of came around to the
project and how you first got a hold of
the book and what it was like for you to
kind of collaborate with Larry McMurtry
on the script well it was sort of faded
that I would do this movie because I was
in a drugstore and
she wasn't in the same one and I was
going through the paperbacks and that
sort of thing said last picture short I
said that sounds like a title of him I
should do and I picked it up and on the
back it said teenage kids growing up in
Texas I said I don't care about that and
I put it down
about two weeks later Sal Mineo was a
dear friend of mine came over and
brought me the same book and said listen
I always wanted to be in this but I'm
too old for it now it's a good book I
think you'd like to read it and they
could make a picture of it and I thought
oh Angie that's peculiar that and thence
and then two weeks later an English
producer gave me the same book so I gave
it to Polly Platt my wife at the time
and I said would you read this and tell
me if it's any good so she read it and
she said well it's a good book I don't
know how you'd make it as a picture but
it's a good book so finally I read it
and I was stumped about how to do it as
a picture but that's what excited me
trying to figure out how to do it and
then I realized the answer was simple
just do the book because the book is
really very very well-written very
well-constructed it was just a question
of leaving out things but the basic flow
of the stories that was there and the
dialogue Larry McMurtry writes the best
regional dialogue of anybody since Mark
Twain I think and so you can't miss with
his dialogue and then was just the
question of getting the construction
right and what to leave out and what to
leave in larry was a bit bored with the
process because he'd written the book
and he you know he that wasn't that
interested but we kept we kept him going
and he was very helpful he said in some
essay he wrote he kept me from flying
off into romantic Heights or something
which I have a tendency to do right I
was reading that when you and Polly
originally went to scout locations that
he had met you in Wichita Falls and then
taken you to his hometown Archer city
and the you you and Polly no no what
happened was he we made medicine Dallas
and
said what do you want to go and I said
well let's look around he's well you
want to see Archer city that's where I
grew up that's the town I wrote about I
said no let's let's it let's let's go
everywhere else first so we drove all
around Texas and as you know it's a big
state we ended up in Corpus Christi I
said [ __ ] we haven't found a good we
haven't found a good place let's fly
back up so we flew back up to Wichita
Falls drove to Archer City as we're
driving into Archer city I said wow this
is perfect and Larry said well ought to
be it's the town I wrote about and that
was really it except that we took
16-millimeter color for the film and it
didn't look as bleak in color as it did
to the eye and that was one of the
reasons we ended up making in black and
white and just it's okay to ask you
about one scene was going to ask you
about that Sam the lion scene at the
tank where the light kind of changes
where that was amazing that was the me I
once asked John Ford about something in
one of his pictures and he said oh I was
just an accident most of the good things
and pictures happen by accident
I'd only made one picture that time and
I thought it really so I asked Orson
Welles it was a friend I said Ford says
the best things in pictures happened by
accident is that right Orson and he said
yes yes yes you could almost say that a
director is a man who presides over
accidents so the Sun came it was a
completely cloudy sky and we sat down to
do the first tank and you know if
somebody said to me where would you like
the Sun to come out that's where it came
out and it came out and it went in and
when I was
and I was a big area where we were
standing and Bob surtees the brilliant
cameraman was all the way over there and
I was over here and I looked at Bob to
ask him basically whether or not the
exposure would be all right with the Sun
coming out so I went and he went so that
was a big help
so I remembered what for didn't Orson
had said so I said well this is an app -
absolutely a happy accident so I let it
go and that was the first take and
that's the one we used well and wasn't
it Orson Welles who suggested black and
white - because that was obviously
really were having visual we were having
a breakfast in his house in Beverly
Hills and and I said I want to get the
depth of field that you had in Citizen
Kane and in touch of evil that depth of
field he says you'll never get it in
color I said well I did I have fairly a
fast film now maybe I can you'll never
get it in color but what am I going to
do why don't you shoot it in black and
white it's an actors movie anyway it'll
look better you know what I always say
about black and white know what or is it
it's the actors friend why do you say
that because every performance looks
better in black and white name me a
great performance in color I dare you so
I went to Bert Schneider who was the
producer who really was the producer of
the picture and I said I'd like to do it
in black and white he said why I said
well I didn't say cuz Orson suggested it
I said because the we can get the period
feeling very quickly with black and
white and I think would be better for
the performances he says let me think
about it a week later he said okay about
a year later I asked him why he'd let it
go so easily and he said I thought it'd
be a novelty he was a great producer of
Bernarda if it's uh okay I was going to
move along to some your co-workers and
ask ask you all how you first came to be
associated with the project and what it
was like being on the set like Sybil I
believe it was your first movie so that
must have been it was my first acting
job and yeah really
pretty good huh I I can't believe it I
can finally dissociate myself from this
seeing myself in the movie do you on my
face is the most wonderful movie I've
ever seen
Oh Peter really oh you darling
haha every one of us you know we you're
only as good as your actors I've said
this before but Ellen Burstyn and I were
a right we arrived in Dallas and then we
took together a little small plane to
Wichita Falls and then we worked with a
dialogue coach a little bit that men
Garriga jason and we never talked
English again
our marriages were falling apart and he
will you know is just awful sad about it
and we kept talking to each other the
same way the whole time was there was
real sad well it was paradise for me
because I had my first acting teacher to
be my first director and we hit it off
pretty good pretty good
and then but but Peter you always said I
didn't have to do the nude scenes
remember that you said you know you
don't have to do that's right look I
didn't want to make this the producers
are very keen to have you do them and I
said well look I want her in the picture
and she's going to not going to do them
it's more important to have her in the
picture than to do the goddamn scene
luckily she did the scenes well I had
good counsel because I asked you Cloris
and Ilene and also Ellen what would you
do if you were me in this movie would
you do the nude scenes and you all said
yes well we got in the bedroom Peter and
Timmy and I and and this one says we
didn't know what we're going to do is
all kind of waiting for Peter to tell us
this is I taken off my clothes for this
scene so Peter and I looked at each
other and we figured out all of us how
to do that as you notice we took her
clothes off a little bit in the closets
and then climbed into bed and they had
planted some a bra and panties for me
and some stuff for him and we said
action he said action we're supposed to
throw out the underwear well I took took
off my underwear and threw it out didn't
I ever you had to do it again are you
doing I just took it off and threw it
away I'd think anything about it
and I heard that you said something it's
okay with me but did you say Peter to
Timmy
something about having a little
something to with me in the movie and
what do you say I don't know she was
middle-aged I think he was a little
afraid of no she
timmi having this thing to do with an
older woman i was middle-aged to tie
remember i thought you were very young
at the time I was very middle-aged I
still am it did all that all of you
would all of you have read the novel as
well before doing it did you read the
book before doing the movie that you
just focused on the script later oh I
read it as a matter of fact a friend of
mine Jim Rogers is here tonight and I
was a model and everybody wanted me to
be in movies and stuff and I turn my
nose up at them and I had a stack of
scripts and stuff and so my friend Jim
Rogers came over and said if he had time
to read any of these and I said no he
said well if you want I'll take them and
I'll see if there's anything worth doing
and he came back with one the last
picture sure he said I think you should
maybe look at this one thank you Jim
Rogers yeah so Timothy how did you
happen to get associated with it and and
you and your brother together that
always seemed interesting that you guys
got to do it together seems like he had
just done was it got Johnny get your
gunner Johnny get his gun Johnny I had a
good agent and I was introduced to
Paulie and Peter and we would sit and
have lunch and he would break toothpicks
and eat his not the smoke yeah he was
great I mean you'd have your tuna and
you had great dreams and and we were
going to make this wonderful picture and
what did you just done Oh Johnny get it
I had done a film called this is only
Wednesday at a small studio in Santa
Barbara and then my second film was
Johnny got his gun with four dalton
trumbo
which he really was very fond of doing
right and our picture was kind of down
from that one wasn't it we kept saying
that I don't know yes you do Peter
in 40 years I forgot no you haven't
Eileen wants to say something yeah
Eileen thanks very much for coming those
are incredible scenes so I have to thank
Eileen for coming up Luke Luke Luke Luke
oh thank you thank you very much an
incredible performance it's on it's on
hello you know first thing I Nick and
the last thing that I can remember I'll
see the first thing what are you doing
thank you I don't know how I did this I
don't know how it happened somebody said
to me they gave me a watch and said EB
you know it baby loves it B loves GB so
somebody gave me that and that's what
started it well is that you Peter well
somebody do you know of anything about
that I gave you a watch but it was later
no no it was before I didn't then it
wasn't me well Eileen we did four or
five pictures together you might what're
you talking about I haven't even done
four or five pictures at all not for a
long time I'm not kidding you know you
come to a time where the head takes over
and you can't remember as well as she I
always had great people crews they would
give me their write out my words and
they would hand them to you so that and
so nobody knew what they were doing and
then I would could say the words but
that's going to happen to everybody
everybody remember that line getting old
yeah that's that's ridiculous I was also
going to ask just been Johnson was so
great in the movie and I was just going
to ask just asking that's the funny
story about then because he turned it
down three times I couldn't figure out
who does she play the part I was having
a hard time casting it and we thought it
originally we hadn't thought maybe have
a Jimmy Stewart and then we thought no
even if you agreed to do it it'd be a
mistake to have a big star in this
little town and then Orson said why
don't you go down in Nashville and see
if you can find a country-western singer
who maybe could play it so I went to
Nashville and that's where I fell in
love with the Hank Williams music but I
didn't find anybody the closest that
came to it was Tex Ritter John Ritter's
father and but I didn't I wasn't right
and then one day I was looking through
the Academy players character men and
there was Ben Johnson now I knew Ben
Johnson because I'd been on the set with
him and Chyna autumn in 1963 and I said
Ben Johnson of course he's perfect it
has to be Ben Johnson you know he's like
whoa that's it so I called him and got
him the script and said and he turned it
down no it's too many words Pete too
many words it's kind of a dirty picture
too so I called John Ford who had put
Ben into pictures and I said Pappy I got
a really good part for old Ben and he
keeps saying there's too many words oh
Jesus he always says that I mean when we
were doing yellow ribbon he'd come on
the set and he'd go to the script girl
he say any words for me today and if she
said yes it's salt and if he if she said
no you just got to ride a horse he'd be
happy where is old Ben well he's in
Tucson well give me his number I'll call
him for you would you yeah I'll call
them so about 15 minutes later before it
caused me baggies and hey I'll do it
really I said um Jesus Christ Ben I mean
Peters got a good part for you what do
you want to do play Duke sidekick your
whole life do the picture so about ten
minutes later the phone rings and my
girl comes in she says it's uh it's it's
Ben Johnson I pick up the throne Oh Ben
you put the old man on me I said what
Ben I really want you to do the picture
hot Pete I don't know is there's so many
words and listening anyway he came into
my office the following week and he took
me an hour and I finally I said Ben if
you do this picture you you could win
the Academy Award why the hell do you
say a thing like that I don't know I
just think you and this part could win
the Oscar well he argued me for a while
and finally he had the script open in
front of him he slammed the script shut
and he said all right I'll do the
goddamn thing and he was the only work
ten days but he was great he was he was
so authentic the other funny moment was
on the set when he had the line about
you catch the clap you wish you never
drunk nothing and we first take he says
you catch the miseries you wish you
never drunk nothing I said miseries he
said I ain't going to say that other
word my mother might want to see this
picture I said Ben miseries doesn't work
for me clap is funny so he said it you
know at that tank Peter it bent grew up
and was actually at that tank as a young
man yeah he lived really close to there
and he knew that country really well so
I'm he identified with it so I thought
that was pretty interesting he was
actually at that tank as a young man
yeah he seemed to fit in so perfectly it
was just across the river yeah all their
relationships in the movie you and Ellen
and you and Timothy and you and your
brother and also Jeff they all seemed so
close and authentic and not even
cinematic I just always wonder gosh was
everybody living together
cuz a motel or herb you know I was sure
y'all liver we all live together all in
cubicles we were on Wichita we knew it
everything was going on in every room
what actors do actors love each other
they love each other and they're lucky
if they get a sing thing that they can
work with other people who are love you
and it's so important that's so true
it's so important and I got kids
I got to listen to everybody in this
vision Otis that Sonny listen to
everybody
do you notice and I got to drive a lot
of cars it's the hardest thing to do is
listen and you did it beautifully thank
you very much Peter
this is again I've seen this picture a
few times not a lot but your left just
full of it full of it you can hardly
stand it so X was it perfect for perfect
film I think but you never get any
release I never I feel like crying but I
can't I mean just ever it you never let
me go after you get me all full of this
picture now I'm going to go home and I
started laughs cause I was thinking
you're you're so great in that last
scene you know the producer we had asked
we had a meeting with the producer they
wanted to make the picture under two
hours so it was released under two hours
and I thought it was too short I had a
meeting with Bert and Bert says you know
why don't you end the picture when he
drives out of town and then he turns
around and drives back and just end it
there
I said Bert I made the picture because
of the last scene oh okay that's true
Phoebe loves EB that's what that's what
I got from him the first thing now I had
black hair didn't I look at it this is
waiting for you unless
I'm not going to dye my hair I promise
this is better than the black I like it
better I really do
oh you is better baby to you oh this is
what was her hair what about it
do you guys oh of course I do everything
to it I saw I first saw Eileen Brennan
off-broadway in a production of a play
called little Mary sunshine and she was
so brilliant she lit up the stage and
when her when she was suggested for this
picture I said Eileen Brennan of course
she'd be wonderful and I don't think he
even read I think he just came in and
told me that you saw Mary Sargent son I
did so he told me that oh maybe I told
you that and I and you know what he gave
when when he got older he gave all the
money to that came from that show to
everybody in the play every and every
time he'd get him some money for the he
did you just give it to all of us I mean
he was such a general that kind of it
man thank you it was really I don't know
where he is I've tried to find him I
think maybe he's passed away we'll get
there
here Eileen and I did four pictures
together I think all the other here I
was also going to ask you so sad that
Polly Platt had died away had passed
away recently and just know that she was
so important and the making of this and
so many other great movies and I think a
lot of people outside of Hollywood don't
know how how she rates she was an
instrumental he was grating up some
great movies a lot of movies and she was
great on this picture the design is
superb she did the production the
production design she couldn't take
credit as production designer because
she wasn't in the Union so just his
design but we got her in the Union for
the next picture what's up doc and then
it was Archie was our cheerleader she
gave us lunches and she told us what to
wear and she made us feel good then we
got to hold a baby and she was like a
mom come on Peter yeah bring out a rat
he was everywhere she was so water for
everybody a whole lot of stuff oh my
gosh did everything yeah but I remember
coming out of the clinic Betsy
dramatically and she glued some hair my
hair onto my cheek I remember glued it
there's River a little kind of risky
thing she was wonderful was and she
really blessed you too because here they
were finding each other and at the
beginning of the picture and all the way
through it and we all knew about it and
and Polly was there with us and and
helping every single person everything
she did my hair yeah for me yeah and she
wouldn't give me my shoes though oh I
was over wanted that pair of shoes so
bad oh oh you can't have everything
no you can't and I have nothing to say
all I can remember is somewhere in the
middle of the 70s civil and I were
getting terrible press terrible press
and Cary Grant called me up he says PETA
with you for God's sake stop telling
people you're happy and stop telling
them you're in love why Carrie because
they're not happy and they're not in
love I said I thought the whole world
loves a lover now don't you believe it
and Peter I was just also going to ask
you about having started before you'd
even made your first movie were a film
critic and a historian and you'd become
friends with all these legends like John
Ford norson Welles and then gone to work
with Roger Corman and how those guys
kind of might have shaped you or helped
you they obviously had to have some some
influence I can well my biggest
influence for me when I was younger was
Stella Adler who was my acting teacher I
studied acting for four years with her
and directed in the theater and then
while I was waiting for to do another
couple of plays in the theater I started
writing about movies and users a way of
learning about movies meeting John Ford
and Orson Welles and Howard Hawks and I
mean I owe them a great deal because
they they helped me a lot just talking
to me and giving me you know like Howard
Hawks said to me always cut on movement
then nobody will notice the cut what a
free piece of advice I think about it
every picture a noise ins thing about
Ford's thing about accidents and just I
learned a lot from them Orson taught me
how to tip he said start out big and
then reduce it
but I owe a lot to those people and I
love them dearly it's the whole world
that everybody was in their 60s or 70s
when I met them and of course they all
passed away and I missed that world so I
still write about it well it all comes
across and a great movie and I think
everybody here is so thankful for for
the job you did and everybody else and
especially for coming out tonight and
sitting up here really appreciate oh
yeah you look we appreciate you Lou
Peter what's McMurtry's pick a movie
than is it Duane's depressed
yeah that's involved is that ever going
to be done I Jeff wants to do it who
Jeff Bridges wants to do it I do too
well we have to talk to Larry and see
well wouldn't it doesn't he want to do
it
he likes the title I think it's the
worst sight I've ever heard I like it
very much really good Dwayne's depressed
Wayne's depressed we all know Wayne is
you want to see Dwayne's depressed it's
a Jeff is depressed but isn't she pretty
oh no but you're wonderful thanks very
much everybody relating on yeah thank
you
thanks to you go
yes
a great picture maybe we all come around
you I mean that heavily I can take that
away from you